hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Eleanor's stairway now
this is just a demo and I believe it's a
short demo to a game that is not
released yet or may have been cancelled
I'm not a hundred percent sure on the
status of the whole game but I have to
say that this looks phenomenal like it
really does look good and I think it was
inspired by or at least some form of
adaptation from Silent Hill PT or the
playable teaser because it's called
Eleanor stairway playable teaser but it
looks like someone had a party here and
I wasn't invited why I'm a cool guy who
likes to party and stuff I'm not an
introvert that sits at home alone
playing video games all day wow this is
hey oh hi how's it going
well this house is too fancy for my
tastes and holy crap it is just going
nuts out there now what's even more
amazing is that this game is made in
unity and I usually don't see good
graphics like this in unity running very
well all that often holy crap what is
that just a drop into the abyss what is
this s scp-087 B whoa hey hey thank you
hi oh that's supposed to look like a
figure of a man ah I just look so cool
okay hello ah yeah okay
all right long narrow hallway with
nothing by me nothing
yeah are they okay we're fine hello good
chunk ah so it is this one hi
Hey
okay okay I think she's just gonna keep
crying like that
hi oh that's a lot of noises happening
what's he's man okay no grandma
Hey
but as exceptionally disconcerting I'm
starting to get spooked up in here in
real Scooby oh geez oh geez
all right let me just get the whales of
the dam for a second find the source of
all tall
oh my god hi breathe one crying am I
supposed to be expected to walk towards
you twitchy face Oh goddamn floaty feet
Mik twitchy face over here don't come
charging at me if you do I will be so
pissed anything behind me no hug come on
hey hello okay oh good
alright let's go for one more loop why
not oh I've been having fun why not
continue on with the party [ __ ]
okay well then
okay statue still there yeah still there
looking creepier than ever it's still
there
hi grandma sorry about the illumination
going away from your face you're just
too ugly for this world apparently hi oh
hi Wow
what the [ __ ] I'm going to go down oh
okay what do what geez oh geez oh geez
ah he's coming for me oh [ __ ] she's
coming for me oh [ __ ] she's coming for
me
hey lady whoa jeez your lack of
animation is ugly disturbing oh hi oh
hey good okay oh no no those it I'm so
short oh no those well made oh really
well made ah man
oh it was so ah man it's always like
these really cool indie horror games you
know they take so much work and it's
usually just like one guy doing it so
having it all crammed into one game
often means that there's not as much as
you would want out of the cool
experience like this it is really good I
really don't know what the status of
this project is look this is well done
that's it really nice okay but either
way this is really well done you can
check this out for yourself I'll put a
link to the the game development page I
hope it's still going on whoever the
developer is this looks great you got a
lot of town this is good stuff here so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[ __ ]